[Music]
and as cantor has come into the game for
the boston suffolk county making a lot
of headlines in this past day including
his footwear with more on that let's
check in with cassidy yeah my guinness
cantor has spoken out on human rights
issues in china for quite some time and
has been critical of nba league partner
nike and its ties to china yesterday on
social media cantor tweeted photos of
the shoes he's wearing tonight which
attacked lebron james's lifetime
partnership with nike on the shoes he
has the line money over morals which he
directed towards james with regard to
labor practices in china now cantor also
criticized lebron this summer on cnn
saying that james was not a strong
enough advocate for the kova 19 vaccine
lebron has not addressed any of cantor's
criticism so far this season guys
all right thank you cassidy and you know
again ennis cantor has been very active
uh speaking about his own country turkey
he's suffered consequences from that and
now this is something he's talked about
quite a bit you you would hope
that he would go to lebron james
directly as well and say hey listen i
feel this way about this what do you
think
um and and i've come to to learn over 30
years dora some cover in the nba
one of the great things is you get to
know these players as men
as husbands as fathers and when they
have an issue that they're serious about
and means something to them i want to
listen to what they have to say
and there's a way to go about it and
and this cantor feels strongly about
this his way of doing it is different
the way most people do it you are
correct and it is consistent with his
past and he has
endured the consequences of his
criticism
of the leadership of his country
both from fellow countrymen who play in
the nba who enes would tell you don't
acknowledge him but that was my first
thought did you reach out to lebron
james first and oh by the way
i don't know how much business the
united states does in terms of billions
of dollars and multiple corporations
not to mention the other nba players who
have relationships with nike a d k d
kyrie you name it you single out one guy
well this has been an issue in and out
of sports
for a long time
lebron do you have any reaction to um
anna's cantor using
your likeness on his shoes in his uh
advocacy for human rights um no i think
if you know me i don't really give too
many people
my energy um
you know and he's definitely not someone
i would give my energy to
um you know trying to use my name to
create
you know an opportunity for himself um
definitely won't comment too much on
that
um if any and that that'll be
where i lay that at um
you know he's always
you know kind of had a you know
a word or two to say you know in my
direction
um you know and as a man you know if you
i really if you got an issue with
somebody you really come up to him get
his opportunity tonight i seen him in
the hallway and walked right by myself
you know thank you